-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now we're going to
get to the news.
The White House is reportedly
lobbying news organizations
to give President Biden
more favorable press coverage,
or as CNN reported it,
"Desperate Biden
begs for compliments."
Ahead of President Biden's
first-ever summit of global
democracies this week,
Chinese officials questioned
how a country like the U.S.
could lecture other nations
given its polarized
domestic politics
and botched
coronavirus response.
Man, it sucks when someone you
don't like makes a good point.
It's like O.J. telling kids
to get vaccinated.
He's not wrong, you just don't
love agreeing with him.
"Listen to 'Juice,' kids,
but not that part."
During his trip today
to Kansas City, Missouri,
President Biden
unveiled new branding
for his Build Back Better plan.
Cool, maybe you can
change the name
so it doesn't sound like
a chiropractor's office
in a strip mall.
During a recent
panel discussion,
West Virginia senator
Joe Manchin
referred to Democrats using
the third-person "they."
Even worse, he referred
to coal lobbyists as "we."
That's right,
Democratic senator Joe Manchin
referred to Democrats
using the third-person "they."
Not cool, but I do
the same thing with my family
when I'm home for the holidays.
They want to go
to Applebee's again.
A boater in Florida
recently discovered
a package in the ocean
that was filled with
$1 million worth of cocaine.
Damn, no wonder he's always
in such a good mood.
I mean, come on.
You don't have the idea
to live in a pineapple
without doing some coke first.
Tampa Bay Buccaneers quarterback
Tom Brady
announced plans this week
for a new collection of NFTs
that will include a stopwatch,
cleats,
the jersey he wore
at the NFL combine,
and even his very first helmet.
And finally, the makers of Oreos
have announced a partnership
with the wine brand Barefoot
to offer an Oreo Thins
red-blend wine
which complements the chocolate
and cream of the cookies.
So if you're craving Oreos
and red wine, don't worry.
You're gonna get through
this breakup.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.